another thing I've noticed is that I
feel like part of the reason is I feel
like there's a lot of tools in the
modern day and age that kind of can act
as friendship simulators or loneliness
like parasocially I mean or not not just
not not even like not even just like
Paris socially but something to make you
trick to trick yourself into making you
feel less lonely even though on the on
distractions yeah it's called
distractions
you know I think we grew up when that
was all kicking off yeah you know we we
had the internet we had games uh and at
the time there was a lot of speculation
from like Boomers being like damn these
kids they're just not learning the life
lessons that we needed and you know I
think it's a lot of [__] horseshit I
think
most people manage to have a completely
well adapted life but the more it goes
on them and the older we get the more I
think yeah I mean I I had a fine time
with it but I think a lot of people
probably did not adapt as well as they
could have yeah because they were so
surrounded by video games and I realized
I was kind of fortunate that my parents
did force me a bunch to socialize or go
out even if even when I hated it like
yeah I did not want to yeah at all I
[__] despised it yeah but I realized
Now That I'm Older I'm like that was
probably necessary that my parents
[__] pulled my Xbox plug out and
forced me to go yeah yeah like it sucks
to admit because I'm like damn this
Boomers a little bit a part of me thinks
that they were kind of right like yeah
like I think if I had unfettered access
to just playing [__] Mini Clip games
like nine hours a day and I didn't talk
to anyone I'd probably be a little weird
yeah and I you know I think I think it's
uh because we just don't know we have no
idea what is gonna happen from all this
online uh access that no no I'm not
playing so the fact that we're just
distracted 24 7 we don't really have to
worry about being lonely because you
could also like let's be honest like if
you're feeling a little bit lonely just
[__] boot up a game and you'll be
you'll be you're distracted until you
fall but on a twitch stream watch trash
days you know watch a movie yeah and
like that does it for the most part but
then I guess after a while of that it
maybe that those emotions kind of creep
in and be a bit too overwhelming right
yeah and then you're not prepared for it
it's just I don't know it's a it's I
find that we've we kind of we like
adopted all this stuff and all this uh
way of living and we didn't really think
about how it kind of affected us and now
even I'm like you know I sometimes I'm
watching [__] I'm like man I wish I just
was hanging out with people instead but
I'm too deep in the source yeah okay
it's weird it's such a weird thing that
I'm battling with and trying to
understand myself okay it's almost like
you don't know what exactly you want
right it's like because because you're
content in the moment of like oh yeah
you know this game is sick or like um
you know watching this YouTube it's like
procrastination right like I know I need
to do something but I also know that uh
I can fool myself by playing games for
two hours yeah and I'm like what is that
what what like what is happening in my
brain there where I'm able to do that
yeah to like push that thing away and
not worry about it because like I was
watching these YouTube videos where
people would
um it was like a guy great I forgot the
name of the channel it's really good
video uh in general this whole Channel
he just basically just coached people
for their finances who just [__] up oh
yes I've seen that and it's like these
people you're watching them you know and
they would they would like get into like
really bad debt and they would just keep
making like really bad financial choices
yeah and then they'd be like hey did you
know you got to pay this bill to like
the IRS and they're like yeah I know I
you know I just haven't got around to it
and I'm like okay like I feel like that
pattern of pushing it away is exactly
what is like kind of stems from the same
behavior of like procrastination with
like video games of work where it's like
okay I don't want to deal with this
problem so I just distract myself and
hopefully I feel better for at least x
amount of time so I remember again yeah
I have to start myself again there's it
reminded me of like the same kind of
behavioral pattern but just way bigger
impacts on your life detrimentally yeah
yeah that opposed to just
procrastinating yeah I used to have such
a bad problem with that when I was a kid
like I always like whenever my parents
would ask me to do something or I had
like some like homework obligations or
you know some obligations I had as a kid
and you know I'd always have this bad
habit of being like uh yeah I'll just do
it tomorrow yeah so I'll still tomorrow
I'll do it the next day and my mom like
said it best she's like if you say you
can do it tomorrow you can do it today
yeah yeah and like that kind of made me
realize like oh [__] yeah I'm like this
is a bad habit to get in in any aspect
Financial or not any aspect just be like
don't it's it's just it's coping like
don't don't Huff the copium you know
like you gotta if there's [__] you gotta
do then you gotta do it yeah because
like you know even for me like as uh I
think I'm like a [__] heavy introvert
right
um I think I'm very lucky now to you
know be married uh and I always have
someone who the [__] version
imagine being married no like every time
I'm feeling just a tiny bit lonely I can
just hang out with Sydney who's also my
best friend at the same time and I'm
just like I never feel lonely anymore
and that's just like I know I'm blessed
and I feel that because every time
Sydney takes her either I'm on uh I'm
away from Sydney or she's on her work
holiday or something even if it's just a
week I have like after about after like
after like the first three days of like
the honeymoon period I'm like I can do
whatever I want I'd have to I'd have to
worry I can watch all the anime I wanted
after that period is over I'm like
damn the house is really empty right now
yeah who do I who do I who do I talk to
and then and then then that's the point
when I start like messaging people to
hang out more often uh you can normally
tell when I when I'm feeling that like
void in my life
um because I think uh a big part of it
is that I think I think it was when in
University when I first started to
really feel the loneliness uh creep in
because you know in University you was
like surrounded by so many people and I
couldn't no matter how many people I was
surrounded with I could never stop that
feeling of just like loneliness because
I wasn't so socially adjusted back then
because going into like from high school
to University
um so like to basically combat that I
remember I just like I had this like
month period where I just tried to go
out like almost every single day and
hang out with who met who met whomever I
think that's I think that's like because
I did that did you do that as well I
think that's just like a thing that
every College shouldn't goes throughout
one point in their life yeah it's just I
think that's just like Universal with
all college students because yeah I did
that exact same thing and it was like
yeah it just kind of came over me one
day and I was just like [__] I'm like
I'm just like not doing anything yeah
and there's like no one around me you
should probably go out and like meet
people yeah and I because because now
like I feel like you know we talked
about our online friends real friends
and yes they definitely can be real
friends but I think there is nothing
that can be substituted for hanging out
with someone like IRL yeah yeah
absolutely yeah
they're like physical that's human touch
yeah they're human touch because I
because I feel like you know even
sometimes when we talk in Discord when
we're doing like uh like a kind of
collab or something on something the
dynamic just shifts like a little bit
you know what I mean there's some
there's like there's something that's
missing there that you don't get that's
a big reason why we want a trash taste
to be iro right because all that exact
reason you know I think when you lose
that like paying attention to each
other's eye contact or body language or
you know somebody paying attention 100
like those are all things that like
really
don't exist when you're like on a zoom
call yeah because I can [__] play
video games and talk to someone like
yeah and I I can make it seem like I'm
paying attention 100 yeah not that it's
a good thing but because you know
because I I'm like oh yeah I'm it's like
it's not stimulating enough because
you're not like taking in all the senses
right yeah I don't know it's it's so I
it's so necessary to have that I think
um I think eye contacts like such a
massive thing yeah yeah I remember doing
like the Kobe times when you'd get on a
call with a mate that you hadn't seen
for a while uh and then the camera would
just be like on the side like that you
just you just see them you look at each
other looking at a screen and not
looking at the camera right yeah and and
you were talking to each other but it
didn't feel like you would
there was a barrier there that I never
like could get used to like they're
hearing you but they're not listening
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm like
are you like old tap I'm not like saying
I can monitor like content right now are
you [__] old Titans or YouTube right
now what are you doing man what are you
doing yeah
um and I feel like with a real human
connection
um there's there is nothing that just
substitutes hanging out in person being
there making eye contact with them and
sure you can you can you can have a fun
time hang out online and stuff like that
um but I feel like if you never meet up
in real life and you like and once you
meet up in real life it's kind of hard
to go back to online that's what I've
noticed as well that's true yeah I think
that's why I find it so hard to do like
collabs with other content creators
whether it's like online because I've
just gotten so use with trash taste now
yeah and a lot of other content that we
do where we are hanging out IRL and it
feels so much more genuine to me right
yeah no for sure yeah I prefer in-person
collaboration yeah definitely more
worthwhile